so
i'm really happy to be here today so i'm
going to give a talk about machine
learning
and um i'm from square and square is
currently headquartered in san francisco
so i'm leading a team called data
science and infrastructure and square
and right now i'm actually visiting
square at new york so i'm not sure
how many of you actually know square
have a new york office and
the director of square new york right
now is pascal
who is sitting right in the audience
there so if you are interested in
visiting square you don't need to go to
san francisco
go to our new york office you can
actually get a feel about like what we
are doing
today i'm um yes today i'm actually
really happy to be here to really talk
about some of the machine learning
efforts
that we are going to do in square and
yeah let me probably start a little bit
from the history from square how many of
you actually heard about square before
that's great that's awesome much better
than i expected
if you go to like san francisco don't
take taxi right now almost every taxi
driver is using square at this point
but probably not too many of you know uh
how
how is school started like what's the
motivation we found at the very
beginning
it's actually in one day in 2009 like
five years ago
and jim and jack who was our co-founders
they actually talked to each other and
jim was literally telling jax that he
was so frustrated
that he is trying to sell a glass faucet
which is going here he was trying to
sell his feet to the other people but
unfortunately they felt
that he failed to do that because he
cannot take credit cards
this is like a two thousand dollar sale
and he cannot take credit card at that
point
so what can you do so we ask can we
actually develop some things in order
for you to take credit card
so that's why two of them like come
together come up with the idea
that why don't we just use mobile phone
plus a device if you take a credit card
payments and this is how square was
founded at that time
so i guess probably most of you know the
device already which is
our iconic square reader very simple
device but
the device is so nice that you can
actually convert the credit card signals
into an audio signal
and then use the audio jacks to pass the
signals into
into our central processing servers so
very nice solution this actually makes a
lot of people believe
square is actually a hardware company
which is not actually not the case the
biggest innovation from square it's
actually not the power it's not the
reader itself
it's actually our business model the
business model
why it's new the new things comes from
the fact that square is actually
first merchant pro account provider who
providing
an intermediate account that we will
take
the buyer's payments first and then we
will hand it out
to our sellers as a second step so we
are basically serving
as an intermediate layers of a payment
system this allows us to
deposit the monies to the buyers or to
the sellers
on the next days no one else can do it
at that point everyone needs to wait for
three or four days to do the processing
but only square can do that
we do that because we do a industrial
leading risk model to support this
application so we will take our risk
we will give you a better customer
experience
and we will grow the products
simultaneously collect more data this
helps us compute
an even better risk model so by
combining these three factors together
here comes square and this is how square
becomes more and more popular
than what it used to be and we did not
stop there
so think about that so originally we
are trying to build a payment system in
order to solve
people's challenges of not being able to
accept credit card
but there's a lot more challenges that
our merchants were facing
so for example a lot of local merchants
that we are
working together with right now they
cannot sell their
products globally they cannot give a san
francisco merchant they cannot sell
things into new york
so that's why we create square markets
that allows them to put the items on
their online storefronts
so can they can have a free e-commerce
portal that allow them to sell products
later online with one single click and
we also realized that it's very
difficult for people to exchange money
so that's why we create square cash so
you can now literally transfer money by
using email transfer
as simple as sending emails for the
other people
so that's how like we are trying to
breaking rules again and again by
providing
new services that the other people do
not expect before
so if we put everything together we do
not build ourselves as a hardware
company we did not view ourselves as a
payment company
we actually view ourselves as an
ecommerce company
and our mission here is that it's trying
to make promise easy
so what does it mean it means that
commerce
essentially is trying to communicate or
exchange values between seller and
buyers
that's about it and it should be as
simple as easy as
user frictionless as communicated
as daily communications so we should
just make seller and buyer
they have very easy platforms to
communicate their values
from each other and this is what we are
striving for
so what are the next big things here we
are talking about payments we have
square market we have square cash
let's reverse engineering the problem a
little let's think about what's the
challenges that our merchants are
currently facing
actually there's a lot of challenges
that the virtual is currently facing
right now
so for example how can you acquire new
customers
that you are not familiar with and how
can you keep your existing customer keep
coming into your store
and how do you detect the fraudulent
activities
and how do you deliver some of your
promoted items to
the existing customers and tell them
okay there is a great promotion i have
today
can i can you come to my store and take
a visit of that
so very difficult problem but i think we
can do that the reason why we can do
that is because
data so once we have the data once we
have a customer relationship database
once we have all the transactional
information
about it from the end to end purchasing
funnels of the customers
we actually know a lot about the
customer and the buyer itself
and this allows us to create the kinds
of data products that can differentiate
from the other the other like general
payment company the other solution the
other
trans company can provide and this is
why we think
theta could be a next big thing for
square
of course i want to give you a little
bit more detail why
square is such a unique place that can
enable data that the other people cannot
do so first
thing is that first thing is about data
scale
we already hand out three millions more
than three millions of
readers square readers to our merchants
right now
and then we are processing more than
30 billions of annualized
payments to our budgets so let me put
this number into context
this number means that so there's only
million of us small and medium sized
merchants in u.s right now
as three million it's actually a bond
it's actually a six millimeter piece of
the market
and also we also realized there is only
55 percent of the
merchants who can take credit cards
there's another 45 percent of merchants
who are not taking credit they only take
cash so this happens a lot in new york
city here i realize that also
and i think those are the great
opportunities that we can
we can um we can fix and we can provide
a
much nicer solution for them and allow
them to start to take critical payment
passing career is definitely one of the
potential way to do it and as a return
we are collecting a lot of data to
enable it
and another thing i want to point out
here is that square is a unique place
that we can access the offline data and
the online data
think about that how many people can
actually access your payment amount
locations and credit score and your
and your inventory information at the
same time
very few people can do that very few
internet companies can do that or very
few payment companies can do that but we
can
we are one of the few places that can
access the offline information
and the online information at the same
time so this allows us to get a holistic
view of the user payment history
from online and also online and this
will help us
to build up the foundations
to build the data products everyone and
connect the people
from offline channels to the online
channels
let me give you some idea about like
what kind of data do we have actually so
um that we can use that to express
additional insights
and this is the sales warning that was
uh
i mean we overlaid it on the u.s map we
collected from one of the thursday
afternoon
or one dollar of our data the thicker
the circle the more sales more you can
get
so you can see there's a lot of big
circles arriving on the
west coast and also on east coast you
can also see there's a lot of
transactions that was happening there
and this is a very sort of an
interesting
set of informations that we can provide
it's probably
harder to read directly from this graph
let me give you a very concrete example
what can you find out from our data
haircut price so if you specifically
look at all the haircut transactions
from all the places all over the country
you can find a very interesting pattern
so the first pattern you can find let me
see so what's the uh what's the first
pattern you think you can find from this
graph
i asked that question to the audience
that's great we even take uh women will
typically spend more money than men
when they have their haircuts big
surprise
okay so i guess like most people will
know that if you have a girlfriend or
your wife
and but i think there's some some more
interesting observation you can get from
this graph
so one of the things is that if you look
at the difference
between the haircut price between women
and men
new york actually have the biggest
difference right now
so that's a very interesting
observations and we don't we don't have
a good explanation for that yet so but
maybe this is a
much more nicer modern places
then women will spend more time to do
haircut and men don't have time to do
hacker and they spend that money on that
so but it's interesting to find it out
and
also there's another interesting
observation it's about tipping
not actually not everyone do tippings
when they are
doing their haircuts but if they pay
tips
typically it's more than 20 so it's
actually
higher than most of the tippings in the
restaurant
so i mean i just want to use this one as
an example to tell you what kind of
insights we have started from scratch
data
so you can you can see like there's a
lot of usable information we can get it
out from there
and it will be useful for us to build
all the customer behavior study
will be used to build a predictive
analytics product that we wanted to have
and also can build out the fraud
detection models that we want
so i thought there's a question
okay so what observation do you have
probably
you have more square readers in west
coast than musicals
that's probably one of the observations
yeah
that's uh i agree that's probably the
case because we actually have a bigger
circumstances
yeah that's good
so after we have so many data that you
can actually do a lot of things
afterwards right so and
for example you can use the data that we
have to detect fraud
that's a very straightforward use case
how can we under the fraudulent
activities of our users
you can also provide the businesses
inside for the merchants
so for example you can tell them what's
your
future sales volumes of your company
and like should you buy some should you
open a new store or should you
expand your business hour like that and
also you can maintain a customer
relationship by maintaining a buyer
database i mean by maintaining all their
favorite items
and once they have previous purchase
behavior
and all put into one single bio database
and finally you can do the information
that's probably
so you can help them to we can build a
recommendation engines
to recommend what are your favorite
items based on your previous
purchase behavior in this case so
there's actually a lot of things we can
do
in order to turn the data into business
better in this case
so that's why um i mean internally we
already have a lot of an interesting
idea to build around the data that we
have
and recently we just posted an article
inquired
and literally just two days ago and
about how square is leveraging data to
improve our use
if you are interested in that feel free
to go to do a search
on the wire articles and take a look
some of the details that how
what's the strategies behind it and how
we're going to use data to leverage our
i mean to improve our business and
improve the seller and buyer experience
so now let me do a deep dive on like how
do we use
machine learning to handle our
industrial leading fraud detection
system
so fraud section is one of the most
critical use cases for square
because we are dealing with a lot of
payments every day
and then we need to find out what are
the fraudulent activities for the users
and just browsing this user and
simultaneously
you don't want to froze you don't want
to freeze the bad
the good news is awesome because uh
at the end you can freeze everyone but
we are not going to do any business at
all so you need to find out a trade-off
between
a false alarm and
so this is some of the data that we have
nowadays we have about
like um 150 uh thousands active user per
day
and then we pass that information to go
through our
raw detection engines which is powered
by our machine learning system
and then we are going to suspect about
two thousand
users everywhere we send that list
to the risk operators to do a manual
transaction
really and the risk operator will
actually make a decision
which one should be frozen and which one
should not be processed
we pick about 100 of them to freeze
every
every day and then we send almost
everyone else
to clear for settlements for the bank so
you have a question
yeah do you have like a hard quota or
hard absolute value with how many
sellers do you
have yeah on a daily basis no we don't
have a hard quarter
i think the question is that do you have
a heart folder or how many sellers are
going to attack
every day and right now we don't have a
headquarters
we only have a super soft quadrant in
the sense that we are actually using a
classification threshold to make a
decision
how many inside the wrong path so for
example during the weekend we have less
select attack and
during the big day they have more but as
long as we control into the range we are
marking about
then our response should have the enough
human resources to happen
so you have a target and then you tune
the algorithms
we actually don't uh it's not as fancy
as that so we just like
have a fixed threshold and then we just
use that fixed classification
or sometimes it could grow as low as 1
000 and 500
but i think growth are reasonable if
it's going to
5 000
i'm just wondering um this flow
seems to be pivoted on sellers when
fraud could be happening from the
buyers also that's right yep very good
questions so
uh the question is that whether we uh
this whole pro is focused on seller so
what if
we have five buyer for us awesome so the
re i mean
need to give a little more explanations
here so in fact the bioflow is taken
care of by the kind
like visa and masters what we are
focusing on here is the seller
so because these master will take that
responsibility
and then if they tell you that buyer
don't have any fraud they will pass them
to us
and then we will actually take the uh
okay we take the responsibility to give
the money to
our seller and at that time but the
charge back for those cell life can come
in like
three i mean three months later so in
that case if we see charge back then we
need to take those money back
but you can see at that point the seller
might bankrupt already
or they might not be in this or they
might have a lot of issues
so that's why we are going to lose the
money because of that but you can see we
lose money because of the sale
instead of losing the money
yeah so you can see we actually have two
questions okay so
um the question is that does the data
from the rooftops actually come back to
the system essentially animators that we
have
so the question yeah i think the the
it's actually the case
so we actually have two kinds of ground
choose data for our training process
here so one is the chargeback data
provided by
our bank the banking partners and that's
the real data real ground choose but you
can only get that three months later
it's going to take you a long time to
collect those data for the risk of data
it's less of a ground truth because it's
relying on manual manual review and
manual feedback there's certain error
rates there but you can get there on the
other day
so so you treat of these two kinds of
training data
one is a fast arrival a bus can you data
that's accurate and the other is a slow
arrived training
more accurate how do you combine these
two things i guess it's a very
interesting question that'd be i could
try
so how many questions can i take now or
should i just take all the questions
whatever you think is best if you want
it okay yeah
why not uh why not leave some of the
questions to the end of the talk
so
but do we really talk about me if you
have some other questions
okay so this is our machine learning
architectures so
first we are going to collect all the
information source that we have we
talked about we have a lot of data
source here
and then we throw that into a machine
learning services
to generate our features and also run
our classifiers and at the end we're
going to generate substitutions
so we generate about three more than 300
features in order to do the
um to do the machine learning rankings
that we want to have
let me give you a little bit idea about
what kind of features that we are
generating right now so these are just
some examples of the features that we
can generate
for example whether you are using a
credit card to make the payments or not
top prevent or non-copy present or you
can use the so-called pen diversity
pan reason it means that literally means
the
credit card number the first 12 digit of
the credit card number i think
so how diverse is your car payments it's
also very interesting features that you
can use during
the process and whether you are using
iphone to do payments or using ipads or
using the other mobile device this could
be another feature
so you can see there's you can divide
and define a lot of features based on
the information source that we are
collecting
so i'm not going to go into too much
detail about that
and let's talk about what kind of model
we are using to
to do the process i mean right now we
are using random forest and boosting
tree to do it but uh
stuff i mean in order to describe random
products we need to start with a
decision tree model
so i think probably most of you know
decision tree model already
right so how many of you know that so
none of you know decision yes okay
that's awesome
i might my suspicion for this audience
like most of you should already know
this oh i saw the opposite question
that's the opposite question doesn't it
yep but i just like um i'll give you
some
quick idea about what's your advantage
why do should we use
decision chiefs so first very easy to
incorporate the structures
i mean this is great and also you can do
dimension reductions by just going
through that
uh decision tree so by remembering not
remembering your data like what k u s
neighbor is doing but you
instead you remember the structures so
you can do it really effectively with
dimensional reduction on top of it
and it's a very powerful enzyme combined
with the ensemble algorithm
that's why like random forest or
boosting tree has been a such a
successful
like classification algorithms in our
current literature
so and if you just combine
a bunch of decisions together you will
get random forest so
um yeah we probably don't need to go
into too much details on like how do you
construct
it oh no so how do you how do we do this
like graph so but i want to talk about a
little bit about the exact process
how do we build the decision tree at
random forests in this case
so first you start with a bunch of
training data
let's assume that's a trinity that you
have
and you first want to come up with a
small sample set
of retraining data so there's a lot of
different choice
for i mean uh building random forests
here but
in this case our sample set will be
smaller than the original training set
so we are not thinking an exact full
size of a
bootstrapping sample and then you're
going to rapidly sample
a square end of the features also so
you're doing another sampling
on the feature space to make the feature
size to be smaller
so and then you use that to find out
what's the best split
between these two things so use your
favorite criteria to find out the split
so you can use genie index or you can
use like the information games choose
your favorite one
and grow the tree make it bigger
so when we start we stop when there's
not enough sample size
inside each of the terminal node so
that's the time we are going to
terminate our entire
growing process so finally just repeat
those
steps in order to grow our regular
forest into a much bigger rental forest
in this case and this was the model that
we have been using
for a long time and we are still
having that model running in our
production system right now
questions what's n approximately in your
case
uh it's about 300 to 400 right now so
let's say the number of features that
we're talking about so the question is
that what the m
approximate is in my cases
so we also talked about boosting tree
here so i mean as a natural extension of
random forest
running boosting on top of the tree is
going i mean there's a lot of a
previous study already showing that
boosting can improve the performance
and this is also something we tried
recently and
the basic idea for boosting i guess
probably a lot of you also
have a brief idea on that so basically
you need to run a weighted sampling
on each of the steps with more and more
focus on the misclassification data
so that each of your new classifier is
going to capture the errors that you are
making from the previous classification
of the previous classifier that you do
before
so you keep doing that keep focus on the
risk classification
misclassified data and finally you come
up with a boosting trees that can
capture the uh all the misclassification
of
the errors that you have been making in
this process
so this is just to give you some like
nice animations on how boosting
is going to work so at the end boosting
tree is time to optimize
its financial loss functions and that's
a very nice
statistical interpretation is why this
pool thinks that the current language
each other
and i'm probably not going into the
detail here
here's some result comparison between
these two things
so we run random forest and we also run
boosting trees
um we are running that on how much
probably
tens of millions of training data right
now
so april main and june means like the
three different textings that we are
using
so it means the testings i was creating
from this book three different months
right now
so you can actually see that the
boosting tree
um it's noticeably outperformed the
random forest is classifiers yes
how many trees how many exiles
yeah so how many trees i mean the
question is that how many trees do we
have in the random parts and how many
trials do we have in the boom
so um for the random forest positive
i've actually tried a lot of different
settings
i think the production setting we are
using is 600 g right now
so but we also try 200 we also try
i think the difference here is not that
big at this point
and also for boosting uh the number of
trials it's about a second so when
they're comparing these two things we
always make sure this true number
i'm curious about performance over time
so question is that like he's curious
about how are we going to
uh what's our typical retraining process
so what's the performance over time
the performance degraded like over time
if we did not retain the model
over and over again the uh the answer is
yes
so if you did not retain this model if
you did not change this model in time
the performance will degrade it
but the degradation rate is actually at
least much slower than i expected
so for example if you right now if you
use a model
that was training let's say using the
data by
the end of 2012 compared with model
using the data training
the end of 2013 um
the difference will not be as
significant as you expected
so there is still some some difference
there so but that's why we keep
retraining
so we are probably retraining on a
monthly basis but
yep
the seasonality is actually okay the
question is that how does the
seasonality affecting the training
performance
so cincinnati is definitely a big factor
here
so typically for example we are going to
see a higher risk rate i think
let me remember the right directions
here so um typically on december we have
the lowest like risk rate
so a lot of good customers coming in on
december to do the i mean some of the
christmas day sales or something like
that so you can see the risk very
smaller
and we are going to see a higher risk
area on january
so um we're still trying to figure out
why january is such a special month yeah
uh it's definitely related to the usage
patent scheme so i think a lot of uh
there are some special ones people are
doing some different things so for
example also related to the events
it's also related to the holidays i mean
how what the holidays happens
so for example january i think i forgot
which event is that right so
um but there were some specific things
that was happening on january that was
like having a constant spike of a risk
rate
and after that after february then it
will
turns out it's going up it will go down
some of them
so but for other exact reasons but
definitely
some external factors
when you measure performance it's based
on
cases essentially right how many cases
do you say fragile versus not
have you seen varying variance in
performance
across the size of the charge yep
so uh the question is that whether we
see a
different kind of a performance against
the size of the charge here
definitely so i think uh the size of the
charger is a very
important factor is related to
performance here that's why we put side
of the charge as a
ranking features in our algorithm also
um
typically i would say um
smaller size of the the size of the
charge if the size of the charger is
like
smaller then the risk array is actually
higher
and if you have a larger size of a
charge then the risk rate is actually
smaller
it's actually a reverse relationship
okay let's move on this is actually the
recall curve
the two algorithm here so you can see
the
the x-axis is the number of payments to
reject and the y-axis is the strong
the fraudulent order cell has been
prevented by the algorithm
the higher the better so you can see
actually the boosting tree was
outperforming the random part is mostly
in the medium risky users in this case
and they perform
relatively similar to each other on the
easy case
and also on the holidays so just give
you some
understanding about what's the recall
curve you're going to see
also some interesting lessons we learned
from this process
especially on data sampling so first
this is a really highly skilled data set
so we only have a one risky cases out of
1000 transactions sometimes
even less than that so you need to
handle this right rare categorization
sample problem so one of the famous
things
you can do is to use weighted sampling
algorithm so
either up sample or upgraded the
positive sample
or downward the negative sample it turns
out it doesn't work so well
so if you put on a high always on
positive sample it will cause some
oscillations in the boosting process if
you put it on a lower weight on the
negative sample
it doesn't show you the real gain so at
the end we just go ahead and do the down
sampling for the negative data
that's actually i mean probably one of
the most simple solutions it turns out
to be the most effective solutions
we are always keeping the negative
ratios to be about three to one percent
three three to one
ratios or ten to one ratios so that's
one of the
i mean we don't have any theoretical
guarantee this is from right ratio for
you to use but this is our
sort of practical observations and it
seems to work pretty well on the data
sets that we have right now
and fewer data typically require fewer
results per chance which is true
and also if we are increasing the um
decreasing the ratios negative to
positive variation to 20 to 1
we actually see a job of recall rate by
10 percent
so and this this result seems to be
consistent across
like a number of one of the training
data that we are testing right now
so again so i don't think we have any
theoretical
guarantee to prove that that's true yet
but it's a good practical
uh consideration that you might want to
consider if you want to run the same
algorithms for yourself
sorry good question
the question is that what's the meaning
of the weight in this case so the
meaning of weight here is that like
if you don't want to downsample your
data in order to solve the skill dataset
uh problem then you need to like apply
an additional multiplication weight on
top of each of the data
instances so you can see for your
positive data you can apply a higher
maybe a 10 times weight so you have
to choose the application you have
algorithms one for
selecting positive
positive and another
so i mean the weight in this case is
that like
um i guess if you are familiar with
in each of the iterations we actually
applying some weight
on top of each of the data instances in
order to build the title market
so in that case you actually applying
weight
so that you can get a higher sampling
rate of that instance
you know to view the new possible so
maybe this this is probably for me to
study about i guess
that's maybe a channel offline on this
one i think this is a pretty standard
process for you to solve because giving
us a
distribution problem
any other questions great
so we talked about machine learning do
we talk about algorithm but another
important pieces here is actually
productionalizing the machine learning
algorithm
system this is actually i would say this
is probably
a very important thing if you want to
run machine learnings in a production
environment so let me talk a little bit
about the lessons that we
learned or the practice we are using in
general
so at the very beginning when we build
up our machine learning system
we use what we call so-called start-up
architectures
which is probably most of the style
company we use
you build ruby on rails on my second
and then you do a lot of select star
from your database and then get
everything into memory
and then just run and simply always on
top of it boom you get a result
that's probably most of people we use
like when the copy is small
and then i mean when your data set was
slowly going up okay you're doing my
signal replications
so you have too much
you're slowly making things a little bit
more and more complicated and then you
realize
replication is so difficult to keep
everything in sync
then that would be the times that you
will find out there are some things
you need to change you know to make
things become more efficient
okay so also there's a lot of problem
for this approach because
everything was just so tight to the
production schema here
everything will be related to your data
schema if one people change your data
table schema you need to change almost
everything else
and if you only have two people making a
database that's fine but if you get 100
people to do it
you're not this is not going to work and
very hard to do complicated analysis if
you turn out to have the features
then you do a lot of complicated
analysis to generate that features
this approach is not going to work so
that's why we have the fat faces how to
change that to a happy basis
okay that's how we scale it out so we
first
change we build java services we change
that to a services
rna architectures and so java is our
choice you can do the other kind of
services but java
actually runs pretty well i mean some of
us are building the gold
services also which also runs pretty
well and if you're a big fan of
if we use that and each of the services
will provide an
api and also we are going to serve our
data from hdfs
and so hdfs is one of our major data
store right now
to serve our data at this point and
building on top of that
you can use your favorite courier
engines you can use height i mean
possible for your engine or you can use
presto
oh you just consume you can use jdbc to
consume a data directly that's also
another choice
after you store the data into the hdfs
or the other how any data scrolls that
you have you also need to do the data
transport
so that's why we actually developed two
solutions here so
one is uh we use two solutions one is
the append only feats this is a
in-house implementation it's one of the
square solutions that
we are using to transfer the data from
one services to another services
and make sure everything was in sync so
one simple example is that
if one user was changing their phone
numbers on the web page
you'll probably want all the related
services to subscribe to this feed
and make changes simultaneously so this
is how we can enable this in general
and also another thing we're using
another system we're using is
coming from linkings this is also using
in some of our data
usage right now so if your data use case
doesn't really care about
uh data loss i mean or you allow certain
degree of
data loss and half life will provide a
much better degrees of
replications and scalabilities on top of
these so it's so
totally different in this case we are
still keeping my single replication
still remains through your pain points
but i don't think
our bodies at this moment i think we can
be very
with it at this point and we are using
proto buffers to
communicate the data across different
services i mean i know some people use
script
some people use profile but profile is
our choice i think it works pretty well
right now
highly availability so essentially our
machine learning services contain a lot
of
services probably five or six services
all together like one service is used to
generate the features
another services is used to run the
machine learning classifiers
and another service is trying to
subscribe all the fees that was related
and then pump that into our future
services so
it has to be highly available if it's
not running on a date you will get an
email from jack telling you
we are losing a lot of money because of
you guys
so yeah so we need to make it highly
available it will never fail
so this is how we do it we have apparel
environment so what we call
a green and blue environment so we
always use only one of the environments
to produce the production traffic but we
keep the other environments
running so why do we want to do that it
actually serves a couple of
purposes so one is that we are going to
make sure the data
is correct we are always tracking the
features we're generating from these two
environments and verifies whether
the features are like uh about the same
with each other at least the range is
about the same with each other
so they can make sure none of the
features all the features are generated
correctly
so and if you happen to see one of the
environment and this is also for the
disaster recovery cases right so if you
happen to see one of the environment is
broken
or for some reason it's not running and
you can quickly switch to another
environment
and start to run things from there so
this is why like parallel environment is
so important to us especially if we want
to enable
a very robust environment for machine
learning this is
a very necessary step for you to do to
do a highly available concept
so before i go into the other machine
learning applications i want to see
whether there is any questions
yes there's lots of ecommerce companies
doing uh
using a third party yep for risk
protection as a service
what do you think of that is that too
poor to you guys to outsource to someone
else
yeah essentially
so um yeah i think this is actually i
think the question is that uh i mean a
lot of companies are e-commerce
especially e-commerce company are using
the third-party solutions to run risk
detections applications and what why do
we want to build things in-house right
so
i think uh there are several things here
so it's first it's related to
engineering cultures
we are we have engineering cultures that
we
believe like um we are capable of
building
our own things and then we actually want
to contribute things back to the open
source communities
in fact like square was one of the major
players that has been contributing a lot
of things
into open source community here and so
we so that's why we have been really
trying to think about building our own
stuff at least we put building our own
stuff as one of our first priority here
the second thing is that we have a lot
of
when we are dealing with a payment data
like this we i mean payment is one of
our
core sort of a competitive advantage or
one of our core expertise
and building risk model as i mentioned
in the second slide like the risk model
itself
actually helped to differentiate
ourselves with the other competitors
and literally the visa and mastery
executive has been telling us
we have the currently the best
industrial leading
raw detection models of all the
providers that we have
and this was like helping us to increase
our profit margins and helping the other
smaller merchants to
be able to build up the trust
relationship with our merchants
so we believe that's why we can do
better and we have the capability to do
it better and that's why we do not
households
so i would love to the other e-commerce
company to consider us to
use our solutions yeah at some point
yeah
cool question yeah the question is
do you run the classifier in real
yeah okay the question is that whether
we are running the classifier in
real time to predict the uh sort of
providing others to our seller
so it's yes or no so if i go back to the
chart that i have right now
so when we are writing the suspicions hi
guys here we are doing that in real time
you will get that suspicions
immediately but we are going to batch up
all the suspicion predictions
into batch i mean uh and then we send
that to risk ops
as a batch instead of sending that to
our risk option
so the reason is that like our current
internal services
is like we only need to deposit the
money to sellers
on the next day instead of like given
that
year so there's no such a requirement
and also from an operation point of
views
it's better for you to just put
everything together and pretend that to
humans rather than keep things coming
from them
and there will be some additional
overhead for manual review process
but it's possible for us to do well in
real time
like risk of detection in the future but
we need to solve the operations
instead of a measurement inside of the
child
question how do you use your data to
change your model
yep so uh i think how often do i change
my data to
to change my model to feed my data back
to change my model
um i think this is really one of the
answers i provide to
one of the questions right now
i mean we want to make it monthly so
sometimes it's going to be longer
sometimes it is shorter
so but i think at least the targeting of
english for this like reaching our model
in the past questions so what is the
request value and what is the sla
response uh the what's up the sla for my
response time right now
depends on what kind of services that
you're talking about so for example when
you
talk when we're talking about the batch
services that we provide to risk
operator
the sl could be long right so it could
be
several hours like as long as we can
provide the
uh the batch feedbacks of our suspicions
by five or five o'clock
in the afternoon then the results will
be happy on that what about this real
time service
oh for this one the services
for the future generation services has
to be in like 100 millisecond type of
range
so because we need to generate a real
high output so one of the reasons behind
it is because we are also supporting the
other applications
such as square markets and square cash
like for square cash you need to
generate the risk uh i mean
fraud detection almost immediately so
within seconds before you send out an
email so that's why the sla for that
kind of location will be different
square markets it's an e-commerce
application so that slo will be also
much smaller
than the register application that we
are talking about
which language or tools you use for the
actual implementation
the question is which languages do i use
for my implementations here right now we
are using
uh the javas i mean we're building the
java savages for
all the machine learning services right
now so java is the major language that's
going to use
and on the front end we are using ruby
but we do not touch too much
vehicles from a machine leaking
perspective but we do need to have
people who do really different
applications
frameworks for java yeah
so for java we're actually using our own
mean also it's building in-house
called a java services container so
that's a
very nice container very very useful so
i'm not sure if you have any kind of
exhaustion or not but i think that's a
pretty nice
okay let me move on to talk about some
other machine learning applications that
we use in square here
so first is square render forest and
this is a very
i mean i'm personally very excited about
this development here
so basically we are building our
in-house random forest
implementations uh and for random
forests and let's go back to our
philosophy here
we believe we have the right engineering
resource to build the
in-house solutions and we actually
before we do that we're actually using
some
pretty standard of the shelf solutions
like scikit-learn
wise island wise twice all have a
solution called random white random
forest and
especially for white rainbow forest it's
a proprietary solution
and we need to get the license version
in order to run it hey it's like a sigma
squad
so the suppose that this baseline is
very difficult to fit
instead we're building our own solution
which is based on java
and you can see that things on the
number i'm showing here it's actually
running faster than the c plus plus
solutions that y's by always supporting
of course there are some implementation
details that are different
and but we are but we are really happy
on that
and the training performance and testing
performance coming out from our
health solutions is almost the same with
the other solutions that we have
so that's why we are switching all of
our applications
into the internal solutions that we are
using
are enjoying the benefit from there
another thing that we are building is a
learning management system and this is
focused on
helping the non-sophisticated users who
build their model
essentially our ideal use case is that
everyone in the companies can build
machine learning models
so you can actually focus on ad hoc
analysis then you can literally just
submit the jobs
with a hive cable and with the feature
you specify in the hive table
then boom you can build machine learning
models out of it
so that's how a learning management
system can help you so it's going to
provide essential repository of
all the machine learning models that we
build in the company and then
aggregating everything in the same
places and then we can allow the other
people to check the results
of the models that you are building so
this is also a system that we are
dealing with
and finally recommendations we just
launched
recommendation a machine learning based
recommendation system to square markets
in this february so if you go to square
markets right now
you can see through say you may also
like
um like a row that was at the end of
each of the item page
this is supported by our recommendation
engines
so based on our internal evaluation
result is providing
10 times more conversion rates compared
with the retina baseline
so it actually works pretty well
so i think that's about it so and
very happy to have the opportunity to
talk about a few of our machine learning
applications
and also talk about some of the new
progress of our machine
learning related like algorithms
systems and some other stuff and
definitely if you have any questions
uh feel free to contact me with this
email and if you would love to know more
about square visit our new office
and this is our twitter account of
course if you happen to be san francisco
also come to our headquarters
and we're happy to host you there so
thank you very much
um
right so i'm wondering you know are you
facing the same issue with this sort of
uh i presume a lot of products that
again don't have
a large amount of producing data that's
basically my recommendation we do have
but it depends on what kind of algorithm
we will use
in order to like uh adjust the post
alcohol
so that is exactly one of the reasons
that there is another recommendation
project
we start with content-based algorithm
things we will focus on like comparing
the similarity between the particles and
uh
and with the uh such as the finals
of each of the content so there's no
goals
yeah so that's why but we want to stop
at that exactly because we realize there
is no stop
here but now after we're collecting the
data all over your home
already that's why we already give you
another
like publisher based on collaboration
based on algorithms
and combine these two things together
and so that my strategy is going to
solve
so the question is that like we imagine
how cost
and uh a bunch of stuff here that's my
future generation happening in hdfs
again the question is like the answer is
yes or no right now we are currently in
a transition stage
that we actually want to move most of
our future generations into hdfs
and uh move into more like scalable like
high phase analysis in this case but we
still have a lot of real-time features
that we want to generate online
so that's why it's it's hot hot at this
point it's a hybrid version
it's not fully on high does not kill you
yes very interesting thank you
that's regarding sharing of data
if you had a sandbox where you could
share information on
uncovering signatures or behaviors of
the
suspects that are you know doing the
wrong thing
you can collaborate and share that
information and help
so collectively if all the uh
organizations like yours will share that
information
there might be benefits of my questions
yeah so the question is that whether we
can share the information
outside so we can collaborate to tackle
this problem
yeah so unfortunately most of our data
we're dealing with right now is related
to payment and transactions and a lot of
data uh it's going to be really really
difficult for us to share the
transactional data that we're talking
about
we might have some other data that could
be shareable like system level data
and um something like the production
system
but not as long as there's anything
related to personal identifiable
information
it's more not going to be shared or to
the external community
yeah question it's not a good question
the performance
yeah that's a good question is there
anything that surprising came out from
our analysis here
so i cannot come up with anything in
video but i can tell you differently
there's a lot of surprises we come up
from the analysis
in general so anything if i can come up
with anything right now
so i need to remember in our meeting
like three months ago we were talking
about very interesting cases but forgot
exactly what it's done but maybe you can
check more offlines but
there's a lot of surprising stuff that
we don't realize
any other questions how much data do i
get
so it depends on what kind of data
you're talking about here
so especially you're talking about
transact how much transactional data we
are keeping we're keeping the
transaction your data
seems the starting of the content yeah
yeah so
they're getting all the data so how much
is it
um i can't tell you the scale but it's
actually a lot
it's definitely a big data problem we
are
maintaining a picture by data datastore
yeah which feature is actually the most
important or most useful
like the top three is this model i think
this is a good time for us to take it
offline
okay so um just give you one example
it's like one of the historical features
would be
very useful uh
like the previous given information for
the users
by probably window application
um
i don't think a thing for the cheese
because we are building ourselves
yeah so it's actually very similar to i
think with a card
so the other thing is the um what uh
what is the music
so for basically
thank you
yeah so you can do things
okay so then let's take the question
offline
you